[Music]
let's go to uh marie in anchorage what's
up marie how's it going
good how are you i'm from preparation
too
yes my question to marie
yes and listen
this is probably one of those moments
when you were like i was gonna tell my
friends i was on the show and then the
lead-in is talking about hemorrhoids and
how angry i get at facebook and
instagram so sorry about that so here's
something i'm going to pause
and now you can just cut it and hand it
directly to them from there and that way
you'll miss
the weird stuff where i talk about
my body all right so how's it going
perfect
it's going good
um my question is i have a son that is
dealing with bullying at school and he
seems to be super unhappy
and he's kind of a pessimistic
personality he's a twin he's um kind of
always been that way a little bit okay
and i'm not sure as a parent
how do you balance
like i want to i mean they talk to me
more than any other i have three older
kids too that are grown
and these boys talk to me i mean i'm so
blessed but
um
you know hearing what they're saying
it's like i want to validate their
feelings i want to listen i want to take
it seriously but at the same time life
is super hard is it normal stuff that
i'm dealing with do i toughen him up you
know how do i balance all of that
because
he is my baby things are harder for him
than his twin
academically socially it's hard for him
to express himself
and um
you know now he's not trying to school
at all
and he's suffering and he's telling me
about it and i just don't know i need
real things to do i need real things
that will help do i take them in and try
medication we tried it when he was
younger do i take them out of school put
them in a new school
you know do i
i don't know i'm off
first
man
that's so hard that's heartbreaking
because you love that little boy right
he is amazing
absolutely amazing i hate that for him i
hate that talented
beyond belief he could maybe
spectrum with things
he is musically talented he can drum
like no other
um
he has a comedic humor that is far
beyond his peers so i don't think they
understand him a room full of adults
would be in stitches
but
i just think that he's 14 and he's you
know he things are super like i said
they're super hard for him and he has a
twin brother that everything's easy for
being compelled
yeah he not only has
the acute feelings of people picking on
them and giving them crap or realizing i
got a funny joke here nobody gets how
funny this is or
i'm drumming on stuff and the teacher's
always hollering at him to be still and
quit moving and this and that but he
also has a picture of
himself in another body doing everything
right
right oh they're not identical they
don't look anything alike so that okay
okay so it's just this weird ugly
brother that's fine that's totally
different
um okay so
great questions and really something
that parents all over have been
wrestling with for a long time
do i just like life is hard and we let's
let them get toughened up if i run in
there and rescue them for everything i'm
actually stealing from them in the
future from their future selves
on i'm preventing them from learning how
to solve problems how to
how to
get resources etc
and
bullying's changed over the last 20
years there's a there's a
digital component to it cyber bullying
right that these things that
our brains have mechanisms
okay okay
um
kids have gotten mean in a way that
they've always been mean kids have
always been ugly and mean
but it has changed the stuff i dealt
with as a kid was brutal and the stuff i
saw my students deal with for us 20
years is another level it is brutal and
i think
lack of civility from parents change in
entertainment has shifted there's just
everything's just
laid on top of each other and whoa
loss of consequences when i was a kid if
you mouthed off to the wrong guy you got
hit in the mouth there was a natural
consequence and i'm not saying that's
great but it was a leveling effect we
all knew you do this this could be a
result that's gone now and if you hit
somebody you go to jail and so there's
just this consequence-free environment
and there's just some kids who are just
paying the price for it
so here's here's the litmus test for me
and i will tell you this is hard for me
because i messed this up with my own kid
and i won't go into too much detail but
i didn't do it the right way
um i didn't listen to him and i missed
some things and um i just have to live
with that and i gotta forgive myself and
then do better next time and um which is
good but i didn't listen
so the difference is kids say mean stuff
that's life
kids
push on each other and get each other's
faces and say things that's that's life
so there's a difference between kids who
are mean and kids experiencing mean
things are uncomfortable things
and
bullying
so the definition of bullying is
a couple of things aggressive
repetitive
intentional
and power dynamic
so is your kids
constantly drumming in class on things
and the kid next to him says hey spaz
hey maniac quit
right
that's that in my mind is not bullying
see that i try to get to the bottom of
that and when he when we do sometimes
i'm like ah
you know i hate that's like not
not that bad but you're thinking i'm
gonna tell him these things right i want
to tell you that exactly where are you
exactly there you go
or is there a group a guy a kid a young
lady is there a group who seek your son
out
to prop themselves up
that they they seek him out to diminish
him to make fun of him to mock him
and they send him
text messages or snapchats that
reinforce that he's less than that he's
dumb and it's pervasive it goes on and
on and on
so when somebody's mean you can avoid
them you walk away or if somebody does a
thing they snap you and say something
like you're an idiot you're stupid
you're always moving around but that's
annoying it's not bullying
it's the pervasive aggressive repetitive
they are seeking my kid out so that's
number one
number two
is
have you involved
school support network yet
so have you called teacher and said hey
my son is telling me these things what
are you saying
yes and they they were unaware of that
of course they wanted names and i
personally like when i'm talking about
certain kids that do these things i mean
i've known these kids forever and i know
they're parents
and
i like to me it hasn't been bad enough
to say anything because i just i don't
want
them to go you know get the wrath of
their parents like you i can't believe
you said that to another child when
they're 14 and they all say really
stupid things all the time like my kids
do it everybody does it
they do but you and i what's just stupid
and roll your eyes and dumb
you and i have 15 or 20 years worth of
wisdom right right and teflon
and our little ones don't and so if you
put yourself in their position as a
parent
and if you got a call that said your son
was saying this to some young little
girl in her class some 14 year old girl
in her class
or to a 14 year old boy in your class
and your blood would boil
make that phone call
yeah
say hey can we
i'm struggling i want my you know we've
known each other for a long time and
have that conversation i would start
with the school
in my situation i did i started with the
school
and i didn't see it clearly enough that
what my son was trying to communicate to
me and we had him in some fancy pants
highfalutin
nonsensical private school and now he's
at a public school loving loving loving
life and that's not a statement on
public schools or private schools
i just thought that because it's fancy
it's gonna be perfect and it was a
disaster for him
they let him know you don't belong here
both
implicitly and explicitly both the
teachers and the students
and
so i didn't listen i kept trying to
drill down into the instances
but what did this kid say that one time
and what i didn't my ten-year-old or
nine-year-old or seven-year-old didn't
have was the ability to articulate i
don't belong there man and every time i
go i i
am i'm not okay
and i didn't have that language and so
we stayed another year and we shouldn't
have and then we got them into a new
environment and it made all the
difference
if you think your kid might be on the
spectrum you mentioned that what makes
you think that
um he just is i mean we've had school
testing done i've never
had
i mean i haven't taken him to a bigger
city and done extensive but um he's kind
of a uh enigma like they don't really
he's kind of all over the place he has
like he's he just tests super high in
some things and just way below
proficiency in others
and
he's i mean he's just
i i wish you could meet him
he sounds amazing he sounds incredible
he he is but uh
communicating how he feels and stuff is
not something that's easy when i have a
conversation with him
and i love him to pieces it's super
frustrating i mean it's like i don't my
you know my other son is like
easy for me to talk to and i have one
that's hard and and even though i'm
listening to him
so healing for him i want you to try
this it may not work but i have had some
moms reach out to me and it just happens
to be moms who reached out and said they
won the lottery with this one i want you
to get a notebook that y'all share
and he owes you
either a written response a story about
the day or a picture or a poem or
something every day and you will respond
oh my gosh see this is why i called i
want real
homework so get a it can be if i'm you i
would overpay for something i would go
to the store and get some leather-bound
non like some
high-falutin something or other make it
all kumbaya special
um and i would say this is for just for
me and you
and okay you right in there
one two and three what were some hard
things about today and one two and three
what were some good things about today
and i want him to i want you to begin to
focus on this can happen at bedtime this
can happen at dinner time dinner time is
really great because it's hard to hide
there
no electronics at the dinner table no
headphones no disappearing
and everyone's going to grow on the
table and say here's
here's the bmws what's the best and
worst parts of the day what's the goods
and the bads and there's all kinds of
different words for that but here's what
we want to do i want us to begin to
verbalize in our house
we look for beauty and we find it
even when things are hard
you have to model that dad has to model
that if he's around um brother has to
model that everybody's got to model it
and often that pessimism is absorbed
somewhere and it may be right because
there's no sunshine
months at a time it may be i don't know
is is he getting that somewhere
um well i mean
i think he lives the same life that
everyone else does in the house i know
you're laughing well just
uh
i can sort of people so
i don't know we just do do do do do so i
don't know i don't i don't know if he's
just another way that he doesn't fit in
because i remember when he was little i
was like you know oscar i said his name
sometimes you have to
choose to be happy like it's just like
you it's a choice you just have to be
like i'm not going to let this get me
down and he's like i try to tell myself
to be happy it doesn't work so let's
change the language change the language
because i think that when you tell
somebody and i i've done this too a
bajillion times
you can choose to be happy i don't think
that's true anymore
i do think
you can choose the things to do the
things that help you become happy
so what i mean by that
i don't i can't sit at home and say be
happy idiot because i want right right
but i can get up and go outside and go
for a walk
and write in my gratitude journal and
write my grandma a note even though she
passed away several years ago i can draw
my right up my five-year-old daughter is
obsessed with getting letters from me
and it's amazing it's so great i can
write her a letter i can do those things
that i know on the back end i can
eat well i can go garden for a while
whatever the thing is i can do the
things that i know are gonna pay off but
those are a physiological response i can
go play my guitar i can go do those
things that's not forcing myself into a
set of feelings
right and so what i would love to see
y'all do is to begin to
back away from that language you should
be feeling like this and sometimes you
just got to do these things
even if you don't feel like it because
you will on the back end yeah
yeah does that make sense yep yep yep
and we have those conversations too
we do all the time
and remember a 14 year old is going to
not listen to you he's going to watch
you
yes and he's not gonna listen to dad
he's gonna watch everybody
and in a culture that you guys are in of
do do do
dropping somebody in who feel feel feels
is
so if you model no i feel that it's hard
and it stinks i'm sorry
and you model and then we go do both and
then that's the gift to him but i do
think it's worth starting with a school
counselor starting with a teacher okay
and setting up a meeting
and you will get a sense very quickly
this teacher doesn't care about my kid
you'll get a sense very quickly
uh this teacher wants to jump in and
solve this and that's not what you're
asking for
will you just keep an eye out on my kid
and
if we get to a place where
you are reading this
daily journal back and forth and by the
way if he doesn't write in this thing
even if he's being obnoxious and
being a 14 year old i love 14 year olds
they're so great they're hilarious and
obnoxious
and so sarcastic i just love them
and he won't write in it then he loses
privilege i mean this is part of
opting into your home that we all
participate in this we all communicate
with one another and i'm giving you a
new avenue and you owe me a poem or a
picture or a song or a how are you doing
you owe me three things you saw today
that were beautiful you owe me those
things every day it's part of our it's
part of our ongoing dialogue in our home
um
if you see those things beginning to dip
down or heaven forbid you he starts
talking about
i don't think i should be here i don't
want to be here self-harm kind of stuff
then you
you flip on the lights and sound the
alarms
but let's work on the communication
stuff so let's come up with a new way to
communicate with one another and it
could be i'll just write hilarious poems
back and forth or you write letters to
each other back whatever that looks like
and
let's talk about not forcing not
choosing to feel a certain way but let's
choose to do the things that are going
to lead us to feeling okay
great great great question marie you're
awesome he's lucky to have you
um that little boy won the lottery with
having you as his mama and
don't hesitate if this pervasive
aggressive intentional over and over
call parents call school
take it from somebody who didn't and i
wish i had off